you took the wrong kid you took the
wrong catwoman DVD kidnap stars Halle
Berry in' is the story of a mother who
is trying desperately to get her son
back
they were at a park one day and somebody
snatched him and she starts chasing them
and that's basically the entire film a
90 minute thrill ride in which you are
with Halle Berry on the worst day of her
life
I'm in my hilarious 'ti background for
another new release review so that
should tell you everything you need to
know but trust me I have a lot more to
say starting with the fact that
relativity media originally made this
film and that was in 2014 since then
this film has had five release dates it
has been pushed back and pushed back and
pushed back because that studio went
into bankruptcy and now it has a new
picture company and it's finally being
released I think you know a day or two
early so who knows but time this review
goes up maybe they will have pulled it
out of theaters again but it's coming
out this weekend and there will be opens
with home video footage of a baby and
you eventually realize it's Halle
Berry's kid and then you see her working
at her job she's a waitress but she
doesn't take shit from anybody some
people are like hey I don't want to eat
that's gonna make my thighs fat and
she's like you could use some of that
lady and walks away and there's some
women in my audience that were like oh
but soon enough this kid gets snatched
at a park and basically the rest of the
film is Halle Berry either in a car on
foot or in some house trying to get her
kid back and this could work there are
films like Joyride with Paul Walker and
Steve Zahn or breakdown with Kurt
Russell even Steven Spielberg's duel has
similarities to this movie and on paper
this movie could actually be really
great in fact the concept is a lot of
fun this could be a really fun thriller
if it was given to the right filmmaker
and the right production crew this film
is a complete failure of production
Halle Berry is doing her best
she's fine in this role it's a fairly
thankless role she basically just runs
around the whole time and goes
my god a lot the editing of this film is
where the problems really come into play
this is some of the worst editing that
I've ever seen in my life the shots jump
back and forth in such jarring ways that
reminded me of the editing in Olivia or
Megaton action movies it's not quite as
bad as this
but there's one sequence in particular
that is closed where Halle is fighting
this woman in her car and they're
choking each other out with seatbelts it
is absolutely atrocious and I kind of
found myself really enjoying it the
first act of kidnap features some of the
worst and most obvious ADR I've ever
heard there's an entire scene with Halle
in her car that doesn't even sound like
her in fact the sound editing and the
final cut of this movie the way
everything's cut together it feels like
a rough cut it feels almost like a work
in progress edit and since the studio
went bankrupt I wouldn't be surprised if
that were half true to pinpoint one
moment in particular during one of the
car chases it fades to black and then
fades back in like six or seven times to
try to make you feel like you're feeling
some sort of adrenaline or something but
it just looks like one of those trailer
moments where they go
this film feels like an eviscerated mess
like if there was a thriller here at
some point it has been cut to shit
visually it's highly uninspired it's a
very ugly looking movie there's one
Dutch angle shot that spins as we
approach her minivan when she's chasing
this cars kidnapped her kid and the
entire time during like this 15 to 20
second Dutch angle spinning shot I was
just asking myself why why is this here
is this like some arthouse moment thrown
into this cliched action thriller there
are so many choices like that throughout
kidnap that are baffling to me and I
won't lie I was entertained by this
movie like really entertained this was a
really entertaining ly bad film it's not
what they
we're going for at all and I feel bad
for them but I really enjoyed watching
this film make no mistake this is a
really bad movie it's honestly one of
the worst of the year but it's the right
type of bad if you like to watch movies
that are so awful you can get a kick out
of it at the same time they also reuse
similar shots multiple times of the
speedometer going from like forty to
sixty like super fast like insanely fast
for a minivan that she's driving it was
rather hilarious and I kind of loved it
there are so many things they could have
done with this movie to make it better
there's one scene in particular where
Halle gets out of her car and she's
running as fast as she can to try to
speed up to this one place to get there
and it could have been like this really
intense moment but they break it up into
so many shots that you can't even really
feel the energy of the moment if they
had just made it like one or two shots
like a continuous panning side shot of
her running as she gets out of the car
and you can really feel like the
intensity of her performance in this
singular moment but you can't because
it's cut to shit and you're constantly
trying to catch up with the Edit of this
movie
it ruins the pacing of what could have
been a perfectly enjoyable throwaway
thriller and it becomes a mind-numbing
so bad that it's a good thriller to add
on to the horrible editing in this movie
towards the end there's this sequence
where this vicious dog is chasing her
and she hides under water and some stuff
happens with one of the villains and
then she is backed up on top of the
water again and the dog is just gone and
it just cuts to her inside the house and
I'm like what about that vicious dog
it's possible that the dog could have
been shot in this altercation that
occurs but this has never made clear in
the movie there are so many things like
that throughout the entire runtime of
kidnap where it feels like there's
missing information missing scenes it's
very much so like that horrible atrocity
the disappointments room with Kate
Beckinsale
strangely enough also another film that
was caught in the middle of relative
media's bankruptcy this is the type of
movie that has the most basic concept
and the most simple story yet they feel
the need to give you a radio voice at
the end of the film to give you a
summation about whatever you just saw
even though we all know what we just saw
this is like a straight-to-dvd thriller
and they still have some guy on the
radio at the end summing up the plot for
us this movie treats its audience like
morons it beats you over the head with
its imagery the Edit is so frustrating
Halle Berry does her best it has some
truly horrific ADR and it feels like
this movie has been ripped to shreds and
just kind of thrown into theaters I'm
going to give kidnapp a D but again I
enjoyed watching this movie about 15
minutes and when Halle Berry was praying
to herself and talking to herself over
and over again in the car I'm like yep
this is going to be entertaining but man
honestly though this is a complete
failure of production guys look forward
to the continuation of my Stephen King
series very soon with more reviews and
as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]